[Música]
a minha iniciação ao mundo da
informática começou quando abriu 10 11
anos
os meus pais fizeram um computador
chamados este espectro talvez algum
sistema cima uma caixinha o teclado
ligava salto visor e para carregar os
jogos de computador
usávamos 18 cassete e com o computador
com esse espectro vem também um livro do
programa são livros a programação
animada chamou de baixa demanda básica
uma agenda econômica bastante simples e
bastante apropriada para introdução à
informática é e eu comecei a seguir os
exemplos do livro
um exemplo simples em aos quadradinhos
as musiquinhas e fui aprendendo aos
poucos o problema é da altura sentindo
já mais ambicioso e decidir tentar
programar computador para jogar contra
mim o jogo do galo
o jogo é o jogo muitos fãs conhecem que
é o dos jogadores competem para
alinharam nas cozinhas e as bolinhas e
de facto depois de algumas tentativas
conseguir que o computador jogar contra
mim jogar e que até era capaz de vencer
seus gastos mal ou pelo menos conseguir
empatar comigo bastante fez facto o jogo
legal é um jogo extremamente simples e
programar jogo legal é ao último momento
que vive ao e e até uma criança de 10
anos de 11 anos consegue fazer e é
trivial é porque o jogo do qual ocorre
num ambiente que o momento que é muito
controlado esta não é medo contra o
atual ambiente entre todas as
possibilidades de tudo que pode
acontecer é conhecida a partida
nós sabemos que as peças não está
naquelas posições antes que é uma peça
vem a seguir à outra e foram todas essas
jogadas são conhecidas a partida
isso permite programar uma regra
específica para cada situação do jogo e
essa regra do estilo já se o jogo tiver
essa situação então melhor jogador nesta
nos concelhos de facto programar o
computador para enfim ser inteligentes e
esta terá sido a minha primeira
geração meu primeiro contacto com o
mundo inclusive parcial e não fazia
idéia é que o passado dos 25 30 anos e
esta é a verdade é exatamente nestas
coisas impossíveis artificial
o jogo com isso é bastante simples
as coisas que não queriam mais
complicadas quando pensamos no jogo
legal para um jogo também conhecem o
jogo de xadrez
o sesi é jogar futebol e vencer 3 por 31
28 tem muito mais peças
as peças podem movimentar as formas mais
complexas
o número de citações juke que existem no
nosso país é de facto muito silvado
futuro é ser impossível nós programas de
computador para que pequenas a situação
do jogo nós tivéssemos uma regra e essa
regra fosse jogar uma granada peça para
transmitir a final e resolver o problema
de criar um jogador de xadrez automático
nós temos uma aproximação bastante festa
que fazemos é construirmos um problema
que adriano vai jogar
eu próprio vai simular respeitar uma
série de jogadas vai tentar jogar bem
nas jogadas à frente 10 20 chegadas à
frente e dentro destas jogadas todas
depois escolhe uma depressa melhor
isso nós já fazemos passarmos do de um
conjunto de regras que nós definimos
esperam uma espécie de pesquisa da
melhor jogada e se ainda assim não é
sucinto o espaço o número de siglas é
tão grande que nós fazemos é também
notamos o computador de sua estratégia e
também notamos um computador alguma
memória no more e dedos dos jogos dos
grandes campeões
os jogos foram realizados no passado e
pensar que nós temos bons jogadores mas
que seja
curiosamente apesar desta aparente
complexidade
o jogo de leiria em jogo da 11 ou
programar um computador do garças por
jogar aqui um jogo legal não é assim tão
grande e não é tão grande porque em um
dos jogos ocorrem não estava entendendo
controlado por cabo frio um ambiente em
que não podem ser muitas situações mas a
situação estão bem definidas as peças
não aparecem nos aparecem nas peças
vermelhas apareceram os jogos peças
pretas e brancas no xadrez importante é
quando assim é
nós temos formas de programar quase
explicitamente o o o comportamento do
computador
estamos realmente complicados quando 100
dias ambientes controlados os jogos de
tabuleiro e vamos para o mundo real
o monte real condição que mais
complicadas porque as regras do jogo não
são conhecidas e mudou há coisas
acontecendo que nós não estávamos à
espera mas vamos a um exemplo
imaginem que queremos construir um
programa de computador que reconhecessem
imagens em fotografia senso fácil só que
vamos ter nos próximos anos ele em jejum
e queira programar como se fosse um jogo
legal então temos uma regra diz se
encontrar nos 10 pixeis branco seguido
de 62 seguido de mais 10 pixels frente
pois provavelmente trata-se de um olho
bom parto no olho depois tivesse mais
outras coisas em algo vermelho aqui
presta nem ver que por seu lado que a
gente acaba por ser uma casa
nós podemos de fato tentar construir um
programa para conhecer cargas diversas
regras
tínhamos maioria funcionando porque
imagine é da imagem em vez de ser uma
imagem de uma pessoa com diferentes
imagens o zeramento lado já começar a
ver como seria não fosse nada sobre uma
sombra da imagem já chegava o o osasco
regra ou é a pessoa por exemplo pode
haver poderia haver uma luz vermelha ou
uma luz muito forte a alteraã ã aquelas
coisas não estávamos à espera dele foi
programar sistemas que interagem com o
mundo real
nós temos lá uma aproximação totalmente
diferente em vez do programa no
computador com regras explícitas do que
quer fazer o que quiser procurar no caso
desse programa no computador pra eu
próprio procurarem as regras precisa
prestar uma tarefa ou seja o computador
acaba por ganhar uma capacidade acaba
por ter uma capacidade de aprendizagem é
e como funciona este o caminho parece
bastante ao técnico e às vezes posso
precisar mas o princípio básico é
bastante simples principais questões que
quer ensinar como usar uma tarefa
qualquer por exemplo em ser imune cara
em gráficas que o que nós fazemos é
francês
computador exemplos fotografias em que
minha cara press exemplo fotografias em
que a minha cara na praça presença dos
objetos ou aparecem outras casas
enquanto não acaba por fazer e encontra
padrões encontra formas geométricas
cores com esses de cores não tem diz
explicitamente que vai tentar procurar
essas possibilidades uma forma mais ou
menos otimizada e com essa coisa de
padrões que identifica o pai de cassete
padrões nas imagens que parecem minha
cara e esses planos não vão estar
presentes nas imagens em que não aparece
a minha cara contou
realmente consegui encontrar esses
padrões pois não é fácil construir uma
regra sobre os padrões
essa parceria com a nossa parceira das
conhecidas do pixies que parece me digo
não é daqui é parceiro do escanteio no
meio e esse é um dos problemas que
aprendem regras é um um salto bastante
grande na forma de abordar problemas
mais graves do mundo real é porque
permite nos construir programas que que
seria impossível construir se nós
tivéssemos explicitamente dizer quais
eram as regras de discussão desse
problema
grande parte do que às vezes 107 9
nós temos ouvido o carro autônomo os
assistentes que falou conosco não é
os temas são a temática é todo o sistema
e todas essas grandes vitórias
estamos agora a assistirem que estão a
passar por todo lado é dar uma forma
desenham a sua existência esta
capacidade é tolerável parte deste
sistema ou partes de sistemas são
programadas
através desta forma de aprendizagem são
programadas explicitamente são
programadas por aprendizagem se assim
nos dois funcionários
será que estamos aqui que eu tenho uma
máquina que vai começar a aprender o uso
dessa mídia grimi previsto pois aprendi
que eu ficava superinteligência escravos
vai de chico tear
será que vai acontecer mas não vai ser
agora que vou descansar vai durar muitos
anos porque porque na realidade essas
todas essas coisas que os de contato
toda a história
todas essas capacidades são aquilo que
existe de facto existem imensos
limitações nessas licitações e todas as
metas que existem precisará quitar tudo
a favor de ações
vamos falar essencialmente duas
limitações e alimentação têm a ver
exatamente com esta forma de
aprendizagem computadores aprendem a
usar uma tarefa específica
quer dizer como quer dizer pra casa nos
ensinaram aos 11 quando aprendesse a
jogar xadrez pantanal como é parte de
seu capital
esse computador que venço kasparov que
não é capaz de ser uma criança jogar o
jogo da mesma forma totalmente diferente
totalmente pronto
nós somos capaz de fazer uma coisa que
todos nós temos até agora tentar
programar as compras não queria ser
capaz de fazer isso no jogo uma coisa
que nós somos que passa muito bem e
transferir conhecimento ou seja nós
aprendemos com uma tarefa não só essa
tarefa está em uma série de outras
tarefas precisas
nós aprendemos muito rapidamente por
causa disso não presenciamos compras a
pena quase sempre do zero
ok interessa que eu tenho de aprender a
ser punido com as como se não soubessem
nada nada porque não sabem nada tem ver
muitos exemplos e nem sempre é fácil nem
sempre é fácil dar exemplos milhões de
árvores milhares de sempre é difícil nós
possamos dar esse exemplo onde a
movimentação bastante bastante grande e
há muito trabalho a ser feito nesta área
é alencar começou a trabalhar
é uma lei que está a desenvolver se
muito rapidamente mas temos e também das
pessoas que essas coisas mão setembro
vai demorar muitos anos até conseguimos
chegar próximo da capacidade de
aprendizagem uma limitação que falar
acho que nem mais interessante acho que
mais ainda que bastante reveladora da
diferença que há entre inclusive central
e em poses artificial
é assim este faça o que você quiser à
medida que os corpos vão ter cada vez
mais capacidade tem que haver mais
consegue ver consegue falar não quero
que eles têm mais capacidade
os computadores também sinta mais
capacidade de processamento das pessoas
isso é uma coisa que as pessoas gostam
gosto mesmo muito a energia eléctrica
muita energia elétrica por meio da
escala
essas coisas fazem o que querem com a
idéia da escala nós se desconstruir um
computador que tem por assim dizer uma
capacidade comparável com o cérebro
humano
nós vamos fazer isso vamos querer
transmitir para um ser humano que o
número de ligações que existem dentro da
nossa cabeça
só sei como consegui um computador caso
o número de ligações que existem na
nossa cabeça e 100% porque compartilhar
das funções que nós - desempenho tem a
ver com o número de ligações que existe
na nossa cabeça não sei se vou fazer
isso
nós construímos uma máquina que além de
ser também de paulo conseguiria
eletricidade equivalente a uma cidade de
30 a 40 mil pessoas
com a tecnologia atual essa máquina
consumiria tanta energia como marca uma
cidade 30 40 mil pessoas para ficarem
com uma compressão também é o cérebro
está em toda a sua plenitude
enquanto estava a desenvolver a teoria
da relatividade estava infantil
mesmo que o mar quando estava a escrever
no mural do convento a gastar e suor e
eu serei eu mesmo valor que elas estão a
gastar neste momento a desenvolver a
minha parte que é exatamente o mesmo
questão embora 2011
meio milhão todo 500 mil vezes menos
meio milhão de vezes - que cita santinha
que enfrentar o maquinário por isso é
que uma máquina tipo é terminator
essa máquina só pode existir a ficção
científica
porque juízo eu tenho uma central
nuclear em vez do coração e sempre
roubar ou então o que aconteceria que em
poucos minutos ou poucas horas de
acompanhamento que elas terminem e há
muitas outras coisas está no limiar da
ficção científica pois é bom das coisas
não está no limiar da ficção científica
e quer passear porque as máquinas têm
que compreender ainda vivia o lugar em
conosco nós temos máquinas que agora
conseguem perceber as palavras não
conseguem seus povos
mas consegue perceber com menos votos
sim mas deu lugar a coisa que mais
complicado mas não conseguiu confirmar
com certeza nós não compreendemos a
linguagem que nós não podemos colocar
nossa linguagem fácil nós sabemos disso
mas precisamos do ponto de vista do
desenvolvimento da vida da terra
uma quer passear com uma cabeçada
linguagem da nossa linguagem surgiu é
ser que desde há muito pouco tempo na
história das vidas e exigiu cerca de 500
milhões de anos depois de uma capacidade
uma capacidade da visão e da linguagem
para ser muito depois da visão
isso é pra casa é fundamentalmente
complexa não sabemos como é que está
sendo ainda é tanto o que não é ficção
científica que acelerar o que é aquela
que nós ultrapassamos a barreira de
proteção mas agora temos máquinas
conseguem ensinar ambientes consegue ver
a gente consegue identificar logo gente
consegue identificar sons dessa maneira
de facto conseguimos conseguimos
ultrapassar estamos a conseguir melhorar
isso é ótimo porque permite também fazer
uma coisa muito dos santos automatizar
processos estavam essencialmente
limitados e quer passar que as máquinas
terão de absorver informação do do
ambiente ea muitos destes vamos dar um
exemplo imagine que nós construímos uma
máquina que pra conseguir ver conseguir
identificá-los gente consegue explorar
todo o lixo urbano que nós produzimos
automaticamente o vapor se quase em
outro vai para a compostagem para
investirmos aquelas pilhas de lixo que
esconder debaixo de montanhas possuímos
uma máquina que esperávamos tudo
i é é por isso que eu sou bastante
otimista sobre tanto otimista no que é
isto nem todos gente artificial
surrealista porque acho que há muitas
limitações que isso que queria que as
pessoas imaginam que a coisa mais
universal que aumentem também são
bastante otimista e acho que nós vamos
anunciar o importante é algo bom vamos
construir algo que vai mudar nossas
vidas pessoal pra melhor
mas antes de terminar o sábado do estado
que é um desafio fazer sutura assim 30
segundos para calcular o vosso com esse
cinto robô robô que é o vosso percentual
quase sempre com álcool é a porcentagem
de tempo vocês passa nas nossas vidas é
executar tarefas pensamento primeiros
trechos que não nos dão prazer
a professora aquilo que não não sou
assim tão complicada que fazer e que
cavam puros tomar bastante tempo é
tarefa como por exemplo reduzir dados no
computador
talvez conduzir talvez por causa da
roupa então a máquina estava totalmente
continente que tenta imaginar nosso dia
a dia e quanto do vosso e ali qual é a
percentagem do tempo vazia
posso dizer com essas tarefas são paulo
agora vou subir para calcularem conheci
o mano
a gente passa é falar com outras pessoas
a tentarem com outros centros urbanos
até imaginar o que se passa entre ser
humano tem que ser com as suas chances
suas aspirações
os seus medos ou são tarefas em que
vocês estão a imaginar coisas que não
existem mais no futuro não existe a
mesma coisa do futuro criar ou ter estas
em que vocês têm de usar é todos os
nossos sentidos não só visando nos ajuda
a vizinhos mas também por lá
o fato de centenas de sensores nós temos
a nossa mel ou mesmo usar a nossa meta
para este fantástico fazer isto
esse é o vosso coeficientes o menino
japonês 400 mil/mês time
chamaram mais a mente se por acaso
chegar à conclusão que o vosso
conhecimento robô é próximo super do
vosso conhecimento humano
não achei estranho tem muita gente aí
também
às vezes a deficiência construir
máquinas que se comportam como seres
humanos somos muito bons a programar ou
menos completar em conta os minutos para
esse início a uma diferença é que ao
contrário dos robôs nordeste
nós podemos interromper o problema
quando quiser vamos decidir nosso
próximo passo é investir no futuro
é importante que não abdiquemos dessa
lei lado que houve queima de ser humano
[Aplausos]